All right, I want to tell you guys about something
that's been sort of going on behind the scenes
at the show, and maybe it'll be interesting
to you and it has everything to do with people
in my audience who are never going to be satisfied
with this program for lack of a better term
and maybe naively over the last few months.
Maybe I thought that I could satisfy them
in some way.
And this doesn't apply to everybody.
But there are also people in the audience
that probably I should sort of be apologizing
to in the sense that I think that my naivete
on this issue may have made the show worse
for some of you over the last few months.
And here is the realization that we've sort
of come to as as a as a point of departure
for what we're talking about today.
It's become very clear over the last, I would
say acutely the last three months, but more
bigger picture over the last year that there's
a slice of the left that's never going to
be satisfied with this program unless I just
become a different person with totally different
views and a different moral grounding and
essentially am no longer me.
And the show is no longer this program.
Now, of course, the entire right is dissatisfied
with this program other than the people who
write to me and say, I don't agree with anything
you say, but I just I watch to see what your
take is.
And I appreciate you being honest about it.
But in terms of the positions I take, of course,
the right doesn't agree with almost anything
that I say on this program.
But there is also a contingent on the left,
which is far louder in the sense in a sense,
because they are at least, you know, nominally
part of my side as the term is.
That is never going to be satisfied with this
program unless I just abandon everything I
believe and take their positions.
So before I get to that, I told this story
years I've been telling the story over the
years, many times when I started the David
Pakman show.
Back then, it was called Mid-week Politics.
It was just a when a Wednesday program.
I was absolutely horrified that somebody might
write to me and be mad that I said something
they disagree with or they might leave an
angry YouTube comment or something like that.
It was scary to me.
And I sort of tried to play the show down
the middle for a while, for a few weeks where
I would report the news and I would say the
left says this and the right says this and
kind of leave it there.
And it was a very boring show.
And it was also unsatisfying because, of course,
I had opinions and I was keeping them to myself
and not really stating them because of this
fear.
And also people got mad anyway, right?
People disagreed that there were two sides
to many stories and they were mad that I presented
both sides as if they were equal.
So the point is I quickly realized that that
couldn't be the show.
It wasn't a satisfying way to me to do the
show.
And it wasn't very useful either, because
I have an opinion that I want to get out there
so that this very quickly became an opinion
program.
And of course, now I'm used to the attacks
and the anti-Semitic comments and thousands
of excuse me, angry, angry YouTube comments
a day or whatever the case may be.
But over the last three to twelve months,
it's become very clear that there is now a
slice of the left that is not going to accept
any position other than their position.
And they won't stop calling me a DNC shill
or other terms unless I take their positions.
And what I want to tell you today is that
it's not going any further.
You're not going to be satisfied with this
program.
And maybe this isn't the program for you.
Let me give you some examples.
OK.
Right now, these are maybe relevant examples.
One is the never Biden crowd, OK?
The never Biden crowd is never going to be
satisfied with what I say unless I join them
and say I'm never going to vote for Biden.
Now, I'm not going to do that at this point
based on what we know.
It's conceivable Joe Biden could go on a killing
spree or something.
And I've changed my mind.
But it's become clear that no matter how I
couched the reality, that based on everything
I know right now, Biden is clearly better
than Trump and I plan to vote for Biden.
I could talk about the Supreme Court.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what I say unless I refuse
to vote for Biden.
There's a very loud contingent that shows
up on my Twitter and read it and whatever.
They're not going to be happy.
Now, the good news is they represent a pretty
small portion of my audience and a pretty
small portion of the left.
But this is not going to be a program for
these folks.
And they will call me a Democratic DNC shill
unless I say never Biden, which, of course,
helps Donald Trump not going to do it.
Let's talk about another example.
This relates to a woman named Tara Reid.
Tara Reid says Joe Biden sexually assaulted
her in 1993.
Now, there was a period of about seven to
10 days where I had a contingent contacting
me increasingly angrily saying, David, you're
terrible, you're a shill because you're not
covering her allegation.
Now, over time, more and more clips have published
my YouTube channel.
Now I believe it's six in total were terror.
Reid's allegations are discussed.
Has this satisfied this slice of the left?
No, course not, because I'm talking about
Tara Reid now, but I'm not saying the right
thing, which I guess.
Is Joe Biden's a rapist?
And I'm not voting for him, but of course
I'm not going to say that Joe Biden hasn't
been convicted of rape.
He's not even accused of rape, if I understand
the allegations correctly.
And the reality is that either Joe Biden or
Donald Trump are going to be president of
the United States on dozens of issues.
I prefer Biden.
Now, this is not some big theatrical, defiant
performance for me.
I'm living my life.
I'm doing the show and advocating for the
policies I support.
And in November, I will essentially have two
choices.
And I've made clear as of right now which
choice I'm going to make.
I have not attacked terror, Reid's credibility.
I've not come out and said her story makes
no sense.
I've not done any of those things.
But this contingent didn't really want me
to just talk about terror, Reid.
They want me to say never Biden.
And they won't be satisfied until I say that
this is no way to run a show if I'm going
to kowtow to these slices of the left that
are hell bent on getting specific statements
out of me.
I could do every show about Tara Reid, but
it's not just about covering it.
It's about taking their position.
And if I don't, I'm a DNC shill and a bad
person.
This probably isn't the show for you.
We've seen this in some other cases as well.
I won't spend a lot lot of time on these.
But when it comes to the Maduro regime in
Venezuela, you know, I've pointed out the
rhetoric that started with Hugo Chavez.
It was very left populist rhetoric.
It became an authoritarian nightmare, a corrupt
judiciary.
It can't be trusted.
The country's resources have been raped and
pillaged by elites to the exclusion of the
majority.
And people write to me and say, David, how
dare you support American intervention in
Venezuela?
And I say, no.
I'm from South America.
I'm very well acquainted with the history
of the region, the disasters of American intervention.
But Chavez was no hero and Maduro is no hero.
And they've been bad for the country and they
hate it.
So it's not really about I support American
intervention, which they know I don't.
It's that I'm not praying at the altar of
Maduro.
They will never be satisfied.
Recently, George W. Bush came out with this
just milquetoast statement about unity around
Corona virus.
And I said, hey, George W. Bush is a war criminal.
But compared to Trump, he sounds like a normal
person, not praise of Bush.
I'm not rehabilitating his image.
And immediately, dozens of comments and hundreds
of Twitter and Facebook posts saying you are
rehabilitating the image of a war criminal.
They will never be satisfied unless I always
say there is no way in which Bush is better
than Trump.
So my renewed effort is and this is my pledge.
I don't care about what these people think
and I'm not going to let it dictate the show.
You can leave me comments on YouTube or tweet
me, write me e-mail, you know, whatever.
Maybe this just isn't the show for you.
Like, I don't watch political shows like mine.
But there must be some show that takes these
positions, right?
Like if you're looking for a never Biden show.
Is there a bite?
Never.
Biden show out there.
I assume there is.
Or if you're looking for a We love Maduro
show or I'm guessing that these shows exist
much like I can't open the eyes of a devout
trombonist.
They're closed off.
So are these leftists on this slice of the
left.
And it's sad, but I can't control it.
All I can control is my show.
And I apologize that over the last three months
there's been a naive it.A where I thought
maybe there would be some way.
It doesn't seem like there is.
They're not going to be satisfied.
Everybody should watch the shows they want,
read what you want, come to your conclusion,
conclusions.
But we're gonna do the show this way.
And that's the way it's going to be.
Now let's get to something positive, which
relates to really great changes for the show.
That's the next thing.